Traductor: Begoña2 Ballester-Olmos
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Si yo les preguntara
en el momento de ver una película
localizada en un espacio idílico
de la Toscana,
cuando ella se levanta de la cama,
se pone la camisa de él y abre la ventana,
¿qué escucharían?
A mí me viene un sonido:
el de la música de las campanas.
Si me viene ese sonido,
es porque quizá comparta con ustedes
que en ciertos momentos de la vida
asociamos ese sonido a ciertos momentos,
a ciertas cosas que nos pasan.
Es porque hay algo de valor en esa música.
Hoy voy a desgranarles
qué valor tiene esa música.
Hay quien dice que es algo innecesario,
que todos llevamos reloj,
que sabemos qué día es fiesta,
que sabemos cuándo fallece
un familiar o un amigo.
Pero me he propuesto hacerles ver
su valor en una ciudad como Valencia.
Porqué es importante esa música.
Cuando viajaba de pequeño
al pueblo de mis abuelos,
no contaba el viaje ni en kilómetros
ni en horas que tardábamos hasta llegar.
Lo contaba en campanarios.
En todos los campanarios
que por la ventana del coche de mi padre
iba viendo por las carreteras nacionales
que cruzaban pueblo a pueblo.
Incluso a otros familiares
les hacía llevarme a la plaza del pueblo
a escuchar el reloj y las campanas.
Y a verlas.
Cuando yo tenía quince años, mi madre,
cansada de oírme hablar de campanas,
se sentó en el salón de casa
y con las Páginas Amarillas en las manos
llamó hasta encontrar
a los campaneros de la catedral.
Y pasó eso porque yo conocía Internet
y me iba los viernes por la tarde al cíber
cuando aún no lo teníamos en casa,
a descargar fotos y textos
que luego volcaba en mi ordenador
a través de esos discos de 3 y medio A
que muchos ya no conocen.
Cuando llegaba me ponía a hablar
de lo que descubría viernes a viernes.
Entonces fue cuando cansada, llamó.
Aquella llamada,
y que la sala de campanas
de la torre del Micalet estuviese abierta,
me abrieron un mundo de música
que aún hoy me fascina.
La primera vez que fui
tuve que subir dos veces,
porque los campaneros de hoy en día
no perdonan el almuerzo.
Y cuando subí, no había nadie.
Y me tocó volver a subir.
Y cuando volví, encontré a unas personas
preparándose para tocar las campanas
de forma manual durante una hora.
Y así lo hicieron.
Con descansos, evidentemente.
Aquella experiencia me dejó fascinado
y me enganchó de una forma inexplicable.
Al día siguiente volvían a ir a tocar,
y yo fui con ellos.
Y así hasta hoy.
Tocar las campanas
es bastante multisensorial.
Es una experiencia que te invade.
Y es muy bonito.
Tener unas masas de bronce
dando vueltas encima de tu cabeza
es algo muy complicado
de explicar con palabras.
A veces a los campaneros
nos cuesta explicarnos con palabras,
porque nuestra forma de expresarnos es
a través del lenguaje de las campanas.
Tienes que estar muy pendiente
de las manos y los pies,
porque una cuerda mal enredada en los pies
puede acabar no muy bien.
Tienes que estar pendiente
de tus compañeros
para que no te pase nada a ti ni a ellos.
Tienes que estar pendiente de tu campana
y también de las demás.
Incluso hemos llegado a crear un lenguaje
entre los campaneros
y a través de golpes y señales
nos comunicamos.
Porque es tan alta la música
que no nos oímos entre nosotros.
Valencia es una ciudad ideal
para ser campanero o campanera.
Y eso no es fruto de la casualidad.
Es fruto del trabajo de un grupo de gente.
De unos "locos", que llamaron.
Que hace unos cuarenta años se juntaban
una vez al año a tocar las campanas.
Y aquel era un momento muy decadente.
Los campaneros empezaban a desaparecer.
Pero no por no encontrar regeneración,
sino porque se instaló en la sociedad
un falso sentimiento de modernidad.
Lo que hacían aquellos campaneros
no era moderno.
Era mucho más moderno poner unos motores,
unos mecanismos rudimentarios
que hicieron que el rico lenguaje
de las campanas desapareciera. O casi.
Porque en aquel momento
entró en escena un colega mío.
Francesc Llop.
Conoció a los campaneros que quedaban,
los entrevistó y consiguió
salvaguardar su conocimiento.
La forma en que tocaban las campanas.
El lenguaje de las campanas
ha organizado nuestra vida como sociedad
desde hace más de 800 años.
Además de avisarnos de ciertas cosas,
ha acompañado nuestro día a día.
Nos ha avisado cuando
algún familiar ha muerto,
o antes de que muriera.
Incluso hacía que mucha gente
del barrio del Carmen,
cuando oían la campana sabían
que había una mujer en el barrio pariendo.
Llegaba a comunicar fielmente
lo que pasaba en cada momento.
Todo un lenguaje global
que se comparte en Europa
pero que está creado para cada torre.
Un lenguaje muy local.
La variedad de toques para decir lo mismo
es casi infinita.
Y todo desapareció,
o estuvo a punto de desaparecer,
porque Francesc consiguió
rescatar ese conocimiento.
Ese grupo de amigos que se juntaba
una vez al año a tocar
tocaba en el campanario de la catedral,
el Micalet.
Hoy se tocan unos 60 días al año.
Para todas las festividades
mayores y menores.
Y tocamos con una partitura que recoge
toques adaptados de una del siglo pasado.
Y que a su vez se adaptó
de otra partitura del XVIII.
Que a su vez se adaptó
de otra partitura del XVI.
Y que a su vez, seguramente,
se adaptaría de otra del siglo XIV
que estamos buscando.
La campana más nueva
que hacemos sonar es de 1735.
Y la más vieja, de 1305.
Sonando igual que el primer día.
Otra campana muy famosa es
la que da nombre a la torre: el Micalet.
El Micalet es una campana,
la que da las horas.
Aparte de ser un símbolo sonoro
para la ciudad,
también es un símbolo de poder.
Porque el año que la fundieron,
en el contrato se dejó escrito
que había que hacer una campana tan grande
que se escuchase
dentro y fuera de las murallas.
Para que además de marcar
el paso del tiempo con sus horas,
marcase el poder de esta ciudad
y que se escuchara desde fuera.
Todo un lenguaje que engloba
estudios antropológicos y sociológicos.
En aquel momento,
cuando los campaneros empezaron a tocar,
tenían muchas dificultades.
Y hoy en día se han ido mejorando
poco a poco.
Esos campaneros siguen tocando
con una fuerza muy importante.
Esos amigos a los que llamaron locos
ahora son considerados
los portadores de un conocimiento
que empieza a trascender.
Además de ser campaneros,
que engloba esta fuerza,
esta música tan alta,
hay muchos otros valores
más allá de los musicales.
Quién me iba a decir, que ser campanero
me llevaría a desarrollar una carrera
en la gestión del patrimonio
cultural e inmaterial.
Quién me iba a decir, que ser campanero
me iba a llevar a congresos
nacionales e internacionales
a explicar qué hacemos en Valencia
con las campanas desde hace 30 años.
O qué hacemos en casa
trabajando voluntariamente
en el ordenador, leyendo o escribiendo.
Se ha generado un sistema para conservar
y mantener este rico patrimonio.
Y además, quién me iba a decir
que iba a formar parte de un tejido social
que comprende
más de 30 grupos de personas
que voluntariamente
hacen sonar las campanas
de más de 30 localidades
de la Comunidad Valenciana.
Esta unión de los campaneros,
este asociacionismo que tenemos,
hace que cojamos mucha fuerza.
Y que nuestro trabajo
se canalice en mejoras para todos.
Por ejemplo,
como aquellos primeros campaneros
en la torre del Micalet,
que aceptaron colaborar
con las instituciones valencianas
cuando la Generalitat decidió llevar
a la Expo de Sevilla, en el 92,
seis campanas valencianas
fundidas antes de 1492.
Cuando aquello pasó yo no estaba.
Mis compañeros hicieron turnos para viajar
a Sevilla a tocarlas todos los días,
para decirle a todo el mundo
lo que empezó a germinar en Valencia.
¿Qué pasó cuando volvieron
esas campanas a Valencia?
Pasaron dos cosas importantes:
La primera, que se empezaba
a restaurar campanas
de una forma respetuosa con la tradición.
Aquellos mecanismos de los años 60
se empezaron a desinstalar
porque destruían, además del sonido,
la forma original en que las campanas
están colgadas en las torres.
Pero ocurrió algo mucho más importante:
cambió la perspectiva de la sociedad
hacia el patrimonio campanero.
La gente empezó a ver con buenos ojos
que se recuperara el patrimonio campanero.
Que hubiese vecinos de cada ciudad
que se decidieran a formar un grupo
y a tocar las campanas.
Ser campanero es muy emocionante.
Pero es mucho más emocionante saber
que podemos ofrecerles la música original.
Que podemos ofrecer a la sociedad
la música que representa los sentimientos
que compartimos todos y todas.
Que genera tantas emociones.
Es un placer hacer sonar las campanas
para que la sociedad las disfrute.
Imagínense ahora,
volviendo a ver esa película
o incluso paseando por Ciutat Vella.
Cuando escuchen esas campanas,
sepan qué valores hay detrás.
El valor de la historia, evidentemente.
El valor del tejido social, de la gente
que se organiza para hacerlas sonar.
Y el valor del esfuerzo
que ayuda a mejorar,
a conservar y mantener
esta tradición y otras.
Quizás con este ejemplo
también podamos empezar a desgranar
qué hay detrás de aquello que nos invade
día a día y no nos damos cuenta,
como la música de campanas.
Qué hay detrás de las cosas
que muchos decían que son inútiles.
que muchos llaman
"la sublime utilidad de la inutilidad".
Aquello que parece
que no tiene ningún sentido
pero tiene uno de los más importantes:
mejorar nuestra calidad de vida
y hacernos más felices.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)